now we can go to uh wigan and speak to
our next guest who is the
shadow foreign secretary lisa nandy so
much to talk to you about uh when it
comes to global affairs but
i just want to start off with uh
coronavirus if i may uh the prime
minister
uh giving an interview to the sunday
telegraph today where he has said a
national lockdown is like a nuclear
deterrent
he doesn't want to have to use it do you
think that boris johnson is right to be
so reluctant
to consider implementing another
national lockdown
well it's right to implement local or
national lockdowns if they're needed but
i think he's right
to aspire to open up the economy again
and get things
moving the trouble is that just saying
it doesn't make it
so and what we actually need is a plan
there are great
gaping holes in the plan that the prime
minister announced
on friday you only have to go down to
the local high street to see what the
problem is
some of the shops and restaurants have
now opened up pubs as well
but many people aren't coming out of
their houses they aren't spending again
in the economy
because they're nervous about what this
means whether there's going to be a
second wave whether the nhs is going to
be overwhelmed
and we really do need to get to grips
with the test
trace and isolate system which the
government accepts is not
still fully functional matt hancock
yesterday
said last night suggested that he might
now start giving
information to public health directors
about positive tests that is long
overdue
and very welcome but we also need to see
tests back within
24 hours we need to see far more
contacts traced and told to isolate far
more quickly
because the government is actually going
backwards on that and we need a mass
winter flu vaccination program as well
there was nothing about that in the
government's plans on friday and unless
people feel confident
that there are plans for a second wave
that is going to be avoided that the nhs
isn't going to be overwhelmed i just
don't think that the economy will get
back up and running
as quickly as the prime minister hopes
okay
now just to move on to china you've
taken a pretty hard-line stance on the
uk's relationship
with china saying that there's been a
naivety about it over the last decade
but of course china is a very important
trading partner to us
particularly at a time when we're
dealing with the economic hits of
coronavirus
leaving the european union the sunday
times today reporting that the chinese
firm tick-tock no longer basing itself
in the uk there's thousands of jobs tied
up there
how concerned are you and how much
should we factor in when thinking about
our relationship with china
that's all important economic
relationship
well we've got to be in a position first
and foremost to safeguard our national
security
and whilst chinese investment is very
welcome
in the uk there are serious concerns
which i've been raising
actually for four years now i was the
shadow energy secretary who raised
concerns about the hinckley point
nuclear power station
that we shouldn't be handing over large
chunks of our
key infrastructure to chinese
government-backed firms here in the uk
and that's what has prompted the route
about huawei for several years now we've
been saying to the government you this
is a high-risk vendor three consecutive
conservative prime ministers have been
told by their own security services that
this is a high-risk vendor
and yet have done nothing to try and
reduce the reliance on this company
in our 5g network it doesn't help
britain's economic prosperity
to have failed to safeguard national
security that's got to be
the plank on which we base everything
else and the truth is that in relation
to huawei
if we'd acted sooner if the government
had paid heed to the warnings not just
from labor but from conservative
backbenchers
as well and from their own security
services then we wouldn't be in a
position now where the rollout of 5g
is delayed and where the costs have
increased because we just didn't have a
plan
okay important of course i said the
government has obviously as you as you
say
reversed its position on huawei um how
concerned are you by some of the human
rights issues in
china i'm particularly thinking about
the treatment of the uyghurs the muslim
minority community in detention camps
allegations that women are being forced
to be sterilized
how should the uk be responding
well we uh we're appalled by what has is
emerging out of the xinjiang
province in relation to the uyghurs and
also very concerned about the pattern of
behavior that we're seeing
develop from the chinese government i
should say our quarrel is not with the
chinese people that relationship is
long deep and important and those
cultural exchanges medical and
scientific
research collaborations are incredibly
important to britain
and to china and to the rest of the
world but we cannot stand by
while we see a pattern of behavior where
freedom democracy
the rule of law and human rights are
abused
and do nothing about it at all now the
government has
started to take steps to address this in
the last few weeks
we've seen a gesture made to the bno
passport holders in hong kong
which has had a very very tough reaction
from the chinese government i think
proving why
i have been saying on others for some
time that we were right to say that we
need a strategy to deal with china
across government the truth is that for
a decade now we've had no strategy at
home no strategy abroad we haven't been
building
our own strategic independence in
relation to things like 5g
and nuclear so that we've got homegrown
alternatives and aren't overly reliant
on china we haven't been building
alliances with other democratic nations
to make sure
that we're not squeezed by china on a
world
stage um we haven't got the strategic
independence that we need and that
absolutely has to change there is also
one very concrete thing that the
government could do
in relation to helping the uyghur
people at the moment and that is to
freeze the assets of any of the chinese
officials
that are involved in those human rights
abuses over in china we've got new
legislation now we've been pushing the
government
to do that for two years the uk should
not be a haven
for people who abuse human rights
overseas
okay another country of course that we
need a strategic
uh relationship with or a strategic
ambition with is
russia uh allegations this week that
russia is behind
online attempts to steal information on
the uk's coronavirus
vaccine now you've accused conservatives
of being
naive in their relationship to china
previously
do you think the labour party has been
naive in its
relationship with russia
well i think we got it wrong on russia
and i made a feature of this during the
labour leadership campaign because i
felt that it really needed to be said
when the salisbury attacks happened we
prevaricated we equivocated we
called for dialogue at a moment when
chemical weapons had been used on the
streets of the uk
and what that did was not only to let an
authoritarian regime that has invaded
its neighbours that has interfered
in elections across european democratic
countries
over several years that has had an
appalling record of human rights against
its own people against lgbt people
muslims and other minorities
and use chemical weapons in the streets
of the uk we didn't just let them off
the hook we also
let the conservative government off the
hook because
i believe the conservatives have been
desperately slow to wake up
to the threat that is posed by the
current
putin administration and we should have
been much quicker
to act in relation to that and by
prevaricating about
issues like salisbury we let the tories
off the hook
i have i strongly believe that that has
to change
and that we have to have a much more
strategic approach
to russia but at the current time what
we've got is a government that on the
one hand
in the foreign office is saying that
they're going to take strong steps
to freeze the assets of russian
officials who are involved in the murder
of sergey
magnitsky and others on the other hand
we've got another government department
uk export finance
which is underwriting to a huge extent
backed by the british taxpayer the
activities of putin's state-backed
oil and gas company gazprom it is the
biggest beneficiary of uk
export finance currently at the moment
this is a very very confused approach
from the uk government and we've got to
have
a review of that finance we've got to
have a more strategic approach in
relation to russia
or we will pay the price pretty clear uh
criticism there are both
uh the previous labour and conservative
response to
russia now it feels like we're rushing
through so many topics here but there
are so much to get through when it comes
to
world affairs with you so i wonder if
you'll forgive me for that
now this week a court ruled that shamima
begum who of course is the bethnal green
schoolgirl who left the united kingdom
to join islamic state in
syria has been granted the right to
return to the united kingdom
to contest the fact that the government
stripped her of her british
citizenship now both you and kia stammer
have previously said
that she's entitled to come back to
britain do you think that schuman bagan
should come back to britain well
we've i think those words were proven
right by the court judgment
that we saw handed down in the last few
days
um i don't welcome the prospect of not
just shamima bagan but
many people coming back to britain who
may be a risk
to us um you know we've got a history in
the uk
in the northwest here of terrorist
incidents just down the road
uh the family of lee rigby are in berry
we had a
ira attack in warrington um when i was a
child which we still remember
every year it's heartbreaking and the
impact is enormous so
i don't welcome the prospect of many
people now being
able to come back to britain who may
pose a risk to us and the security
services say that they do
but the home secretary has made a real
mess of this there were two ways to
handle it
one would have been to take legal advice
and see if there was a basis for denying
not just shamima bagan but many other
people
who wanted to appeal access to britain
whether there was a way to give them a
fair trial
overseas the other would have been to
bring them back
to britain in order to face justice and
what happened
was neither we had a home secretary who
shot from the hip
who tried to play to the gallery and as
a consequence we're now
we now face a real problem shamima begum
is coming back
to have a trial uh she has a right to a
fair trial the courts have
have determined that but it sets a
precedent so many other people
may now return from overseas and it's
not at all clear that the uk
is prepared for that we could have
avoided this mess if the home secretary
had just taken proper legal advice
observed the rule of law and handled
this process properly
in the first place at the same though at
the same time though um
because we are uh haven't got too much
time left in the interview but some
people
listening to you will think that
actually why is labour effectively
siding with shamima bagan someone who
they would feel gave up her right to
british citizenship
when she made the decision to join
islamic state
well i don't think that is about siding
with somebody who
joined islamic state and sought to harm
people in
britain i think that is about saying
that people who take those
actions must face justice
and there were two ways that could have
happened the home secretary could have
taken
proper legal advice to see if there was
a basis to deny her entry into the uk
and dealt with it that way or he said
javid at the time could have brought
shamima bagan back to the uk
to face justice through the british
justice system but he didn't either
and as a consequence this case has been
dragging on for years and we're now in a
position where
it is it's clear that shamima begum is
returning to the uk but it's not at all
clear that we're prepared for that
or for the precedent that this
potentially sets we should have just
handled this properly
in order to make sure that justice was
done
and we should have been thinking about a
strategy to make sure that
that this doesn't keep repeatedly
happening you know one of the things
that
that was said at the time was that a 15
year old
from bethnal green travelling uh making
that
disastrous choice to travel overseas in
order to join
isis fighters um this has happened too
often
okay thank you thank you uh for that now
later on in the programme another
important story that i'm keen to talk to
you about and later on the program
we're going to be talking to the mother
of harry dunn who of course is the
british teenager who was killed in a
road traffic accident
the other person involved and the
crewless then fled to the united states
where she claimed diplomatic immunity
now they want the case raised with the
u.s secretary of state mike pompeo when
he's in
the uk next week what practically
can the british government do about this
awful case or is there nothing they can
more that they can do
well i think the first thing that would
really help the family who i've
met with and admire enormously for their
for their bravery and their stoicism
through all of this is to be honest
about what happened there were real
inconsistencies in the account that the
foreign secretary has given
about how ann sakulas came to leave the
united kingdom
it's starting to look likely thanks to
the work of sky news and others
who've been investigating this that she
was given the green light to leave by
the united kingdom
wrongly it appears and the family wasn't
informed so the family need honesty they
deserve that but they also need
a trial they need a verdict um they need
justice for harry
and when kirsten and i met with the u.s
ambassador to the uk we raised this case
i think there is a willingness on the
part of the u.s authorities
to actually try to resolve this but we
need
the uk government to to step up and
approach this with a level of honesty
and transparency that has been
completely
lacking so far it's disrespectful to
harry but it also
sends a warning signal to a lot of
people around the uk
because if this happened to your child i
mean i would want to know
that the british government was on my
side that it wasn't secretly working
with other countries
in order to let the person who did it
off the hook
this family deserves justice and we've
got to make sure that they get it
okay and of course we'll be hearing the
government's response to that with
dominic raab the foreign secretary later
on in the programme as well